parlons peu parlons bien ça ça déchire
ça c'est le constat de base
nathan je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
ça c'est là sur face book 2 de microsoft
alors c'est un modèle qui est pas sorti
aujourd'hui qui est sorti il ya quelques
temps j'avais pas pu essayer et j'avais
vraiment vraiment envie de l'essayer du
coup j'ai dit à microsoft et microsoft
tu me la traite un certain dégoût d'eux
on dit on te la fais péter et donc ils
l'ont fait péter et je suis vraiment
hyper content parce que c'est un produit
très très atypique c'est un produit qui
est très très particulier c'est un
produit qui est extrêmement rasées mais
c'est un produit hyper performant hyper
polyvalent hyper complet c'est un
produit très puissant mais qui par
contre pas destiné à tout le monde
après ce qui va faire un peu votre chose
qui va égayer votre choix c'est vraiment
une question de budget parce que c'est
un produit qui dans sa version assez
évolué et ce qui à mon avis il faut sur
cette bécane là coûte relativement cher
alors avant de vous parler de prix avant
vous expliquer pourquoi qui commet
toussa toussa toussa toussa
on a regardé on va toucher on va la
fripe est un peu de tous les côtés et
vous allez voir cette surface 2-2
elle détient grave
[Musique]
voilà la bête alors là on l'a vraiment
version fermée comme si vous allez
ouvrir face à vous ce qui est super
intéressant est ce qui est vraiment top
là dessus si cette charnière c'est
vraiment son ads à la race à la tipp
c'est vraiment incroyable vous allez
vraiment une machine qui est vraiment
très très très belle pouvez regarder
sous tous les angles
elle est vraiment cheap et elle
ressemble à aucune autre ici là vous
avez une caméra de 8 mégapixels
on va retrouver l'usbc pour surface
connect on a aussi une prise jack alors
une prise jack et placé au niveau de
l'écran vous allez voir pourquoi tout à
l'heure de l'autre côté on va retrouver
de l'usb type ah ça c'est plutôt bien
qu'il y en ait encore là dessus et un
lecteur de cartes sd beaucoup c'est pas
un lecteur de cartes microsd qui ont
vraiment croire que microsoft a pris
prix a pris le pli c'est dur à dire
appuyé le pris le pli est pris le pli de
se dire et à qui s'adressait à des
vidéastes à des photographes
en tout cas à des personnes quel intérêt
il ya des cartes sd la tendance est
plutôt cool la bécane s'ouvre très
simplement vous l'ouvrez un ordinateur
relativement classique
vous avez un windows 10 pro vous avez
windows et l'oim windows relativement
standard une machine un peu classique
c'est un ordinateur vous avez une petite
webcam de 5 mégapixels voit les films et
à l'avant comme à l'arrière en full hd
ça marche très bien bon il exceptionnel
là dessus le clavier je trouve juste
super le retour de touche est vraiment
génial l'expérience de frappe est
vraiment top
c'est vraiment une très très très belle
réussite c'est vraiment une machine avec
un design qui est vraiment très très
très très racé le côté magnésium est
juste magnifique vous avez déborde sur
le côté se passe-t-il voyez bien qu'ils
sont légèrement arrondi fin il ya
vraiment un travail qui est magnifique
là dessus microsoft a vraiment très très
bien réussi sa copie et là où ça devient
complètement 27 ordinateur vous avec à
appuyer tours de magie attention on
attend en attendant temps et paf votre
ordinateur se transforme devient une
tablette phare une tablette à quelque
chose près en tout cas vous pouvez
complètement venir détachées l'écran
vous passez du coup en mode tablette
c'est complètement adaptatif c'est juste
énorme
et là vous l'utilisez voilà ça vous fait
une énorme tempête alors là c'est la
version 15 pouces c'est très très grand
je reconnais très très grand contre
d'habitués des tablettes qui font 10
pouces 12 pouces vous arriver là dessus
sur un 15 pouces et bao un astre
d'autres par contre c'est assez
appréciable parce que vous avez une
vraie belle lisibilité pour vous mettez
des films dessus vous avez un confort de
visionnage qui est complètement absolue
qui est complètement dingue mais le
grand atout de cette décade c'est qu'en
réalité vous avez quatre modes saas est
assez standard c'est mon ordinateur dont
vous l'ouvrez vous le faire mais c'est
un ordinateur jusque là je vous apprends
absolument rien ça marche tout seul
ensuite vous voulez directement ici vous
avez un petit bouton vous appuyez dessus
ça va venir vous déverrouillez la
machine vous allez avoir un message qui
va paraître up prêts à des tâches et là
vous le prenez vous tirer et il s'enlève
tout seul la techno est complètement
folle c'est un système aimante et vous
pouvez le prendre vous pouvez tirer
dessus
autant que vous voulez dès le départ si
vous n'avez pas comment ça marche c'est
pas hyper intuitif ça ne fonctionnera
pas par contre une fois vous avez capté
c'est un vrai plaisir
et puis on s'arrête pas de jouer avec en
tout cas au début c'est vraiment hyper
agréable donc vous avez un le mode
ordinateur
2 c'est le mode tablette et comme je
vous le dis franchement c'est énorme
ensuite vous prenez votre écran vous
voulez le positionner vous voulez le
clip c'est à l'envers là dessus vous le
prenez vous le clip sale envers vous le
mettez comme ça ça vous fait le mode
studio en fait le mode studio vous
l'avez lorsque vous l'avez poser écran à
l'envers vous avez la courbure comme ça
ça vous le pose à plat et là pourrait
venir bosser directement dessus faire ce
que vous avez à faire avec votre écran
tactile
c'est vraiment terrible ça marche super
bien en plus le tactile est vraiment
vraiment vraiment génial hyper hyper
appréciable l'écran est complètement fou
hein et mode ce qu'on appelle les modes
d'affichage on le prend on lève on le
tourne comme ça et là vous allez pouvoir
bosser dessus comme vous voulez vous lui
mettez l'inclinaison que vous voulez ça
ces modes d'affichage j'imagine surtout
pour des graphistes ça vous fait une
espèce de tablettes graphiques relever
comme ça très facile à manipuler vous
avez un stylet vous pouvez dessiner
dessus pour la prise de notes aussi
c'est franchement bien pour regarder un
film dans le train why not vous le
mettez comme vous voulez c'est vraiment
une machine qui est hyper polyvalente et
c'est ça
tout l'intérêt de cette bécane
l'écran est vraiment vraiment vraiment
bluffant vous avez un écran pixel cents
c'est un écran qui est complètement
maîtrisé de la part de microsoft en plus
d'avoir un tactile qui est complètement
ouf qui marche très très bien bon
vraiment bonne qualité comme on a pu
voir sur les différents modèles
notamment sur la surface pro on a
vraiment une qualité qui complètement
maîtrisé et en plus élevé qu'elle
n'avait proposé en deux versions soit
vous avez un écran 13,5 pouces avec une
résolution de 3000 par 2000 c'est un
format 3 2 très particulier en tout cas
ça marche hyperliens à 267 pixels par
pouce soit vous avez un écran 15 pouces
3240 2160 pixels à 2 160 pixels par
pouce ça marche bien la qualité est là
c'est vraiment vraiment cool
il a une très bonne luminosité que ce
soit pour de la bureautique pour de
gagny pour ce que vous voulez
l'écran pixel sense est une petite bombe
atomique et marche très bien pour moi il
ya un truc que je faut il reprocher à
cet écran c'est lorsque vous l'utilisez
comme ça vous n'avez pas comme sur la
surface pro cet espèce de petit chevalet
vous pouvez ouvrir ce que vous pouvez la
pause est comme ça après c'est un
reproche mais d'un autre côté je
comprends c'est à dire que je me dis
qu'au final cette machine si avant toi
ordinateur vous avez votre clavier qui
est là c'est très clairement un
ordinateur donc si jamais je vais lui
poser derrière la petite tablette
je vais complexifier la gamme parce que
ça c'est ce que vous retrouvez sur la
surface pro alors c'est pas la même
taille d'écran mais c'est vraiment à
l'adn de la surface pro je le prends je
le pose je me dis que j'ai un kleenex
par brancher dessus en gros si je fais
ça cette bécane je vais transformer en
train espèce d'hybride ont une surface
pro et un ordinateur et là très
clairement dans la gamme on se perd
c'est le bordel donc au final ma
réflexion c'est de me dire ah c'est
dommage c'est franchement dommage
et puis en y réfléchissant je trouve que
c'est plutôt une bonne idée
c'est plutôt bien réfléchie de la part
de microsoft comme ça moi on distingue
vraiment les gammes pour les sépare ça
c'est plutôt malin après une fois vous
l'utiliser comme ça en mode tablette
vous avez cette espèce de truc là qu'ils
restent là oui mais qu'est ce que je
vais faire de ce clavier c'est parce
qu'être plus jolie mais bon de l'autre
côté moi je vois pas trop ce que je
pourrais en faire sinon et une fois
qu'il est comme ça par contre
là ça ne bouge plus c'est un moment
c'est très très bien fabriqué c'est
assez atypiques comme produit maintenant
je veux qu'on parle performance parce
que ça c'est vraiment un point très très
très important sur cette bécane vous
avez deux confie possible vous avez soit
un intel core i5 soit un intel core i7
très clairement pour partir sur une
machine comme celle-là je vous ai tout à
l'heure il faut franchement un intel
core i7 sont pas l'intérêt d'aller
prendre un intel core i5 d'autant plus
que si vous preniez intel core i5 vous
avez une carte graphique qui est intégré
vous n'êtes pas une carte graphique à
part par contre si vous prenez en 13
pouces avec un intel core i7 vous avez
une nvidia geforce gtx 1050 ça c'est
cool
par contre si vous le prenez en 15
pouces intégré intel core i7 vous avez
une nvidia gtx 1060 avec 6 giga de ram
dédiée à la partie graphique ça
franchement c'est hyper cool alors par
contre c'est cool mais ça se paye en
termes de ram vous avez deux versions
soit 8 gigas de ram soit 16 giga de ram
si vous prenez intel core i5 8 gigas de
ram ça sera que ça ne pouvait pas aller
sur un 16 giga de ram par contre si vous
prenez une quelconque 17 vous pouvez
prendre soin 8 gigas de ram soit 16 giga
de ram alors attention
vraiment vous connaissiez vos besoins
aujourd'hui et vous arriviez anticiper
vos besoins demain parce que si vous
prenez 8 gigas de ram est passé giga de
ram
vous pouvez être limitée à un moment si
vous faites de la vidéo mais de la vidéo
full hd
bon vous êtes tranquille maintenant si
vous voulez aller beaucoup plus loin
avoir plus de fluidité sur les soins de
la 4k cia drame
ça sera le grand grand grand minimum
toute façon sur sur lesquels il faut
toujours se poser la question dès le
départ de ses besoins pour la
configuration de ses besoins actuels
mais de ses besoins futurs
pareil en termes de stockage j'avais
choix 128 go 256 go 512 gia voire
carrément un terrain dites vous bien
tout à votre machine est configurée vous
allez pas ensuite pouvoir changer votre
ssd à l'intérieur niet walo douze ans
plus que vous avez pas sur l'usb type c
du thunderbolt roi dont des disques
externes hyper rapide vous n'êtes pas
pouvoir en branches et réfléchie c'est
vraiment à vos besoins tout de suite en
n2 passer votre commande
je vous parle de performance va t'en
faut que je vous parle d'autonomie
microsoft nous a annoncé 17 heures en
tout cas jusqu'à 17 heures alors je vous
le dis tout de suite les 17 heures les
ai pas eus par contre bonne dizaine
d'heure tranquillement 10h facilement
c'est vraiment une machine qui a une
excellente autonomie
c'est vraiment très très long parce que
vous avez un deux ans dans ce même parc
de tendance et 1,4 en vraie bonne
autonomie là dessus alors après ça
dépend toujours l'autonomie de ce que
vous allez en faire je vous dirai pas si
vous allez jouer parce que pour moi
c'est pas une sorte d atari fait pour le
gaming vous allez pouvoir faire tourner
des jeux dessus sans problème vous allez
pouvoir faire à tourner planty sans
aucun problème plein de jeux qui a
absolument aucun souci mais très
clairement cette machine là c'est pas du
tout du tout du tout son adn jeudi rex
le gaming
ça va être une utilisation vraiment
secondaire voire tertiaire c'est
vraiment pas du tout ce qu'on va faire
en premier très clairement l'adn de
cette bécane
c'est un ordinateur qui est destiné aux
professionnels
voilà professionnels qui cherchent une
bécane polyvalente
et quand je dis professionnels je pense
surtout aux graphistes très clairement
pour moi cet ordinateur est fait pour
les graphistes vous le voyez à cannes
ecluse âge parce que lorsque vous
l'ouvrez comme l'ordinateur classique ça
c'est du gros standards c'est du
classique
c'est effectivement fait pour tout un
chacun de toute façon même si vous êtes
un professionnel de la bureautique vous
en faites aucun problème hop windows et
l'eau qui déverrouille c'est formidable
ça va vite
vous allez voir le truc est complètement
fou c'est à dire que lorsque vous l'avez
levé hop tchador tant que ça fait
lorsque vous l'avez ouvert comme ça vous
d'été sur vos genoux vous mettez
quelque part pour poser pour venir
dessiner pour bien travailler ça très
clairement c'est un but ensuite je suis
graphiste j'ai maintenant besoin que la
tablette me serve pourquoi refaire et du
graff liste me direz vous je le prends
je positionne comme ça et là maintenant
je vais vraiment devant moi d'une façon
vraiment très très très intuitive à la
cette inclinaison en plus il ya un
avantage c'est qu'il ya vraiment d'écran
qui a du poids
donc il ya une vraie belle répartition
du poids au niveau de la chine alors
attention lorsque vous le mettez un peu
à l'écart il recommence un petit peu a
basculé par contre vous le mettez comme
ça vous venez travailler dessus vous
voulez dessinée c'est vraiment bien
alors comme il est un peu lourd vous
avez aussi un écran qui fait un petit
peu ressort là vous voyez là voyez il ya
un côté un peu ressort bon ça c'est à
dire du poids parce que l'ordinateur est
situé directement dans l'écran il met
par contre le fait de l'avoir sur ce
mode là de cette manière là c'est
vraiment hyper pratique et très
clairement pour moi ça s'est dédié aux
infographistes et ensuite lorsque vous
le posez tout à plat comme ça pour
tourner un par contre si non vous
pencher la tête il est posé comme ça
vous vous laisse décider dessus ça sera
vraiment pour les créatifs pour venir
dessiner alors ça qui peut le plus peut
le moins pour les créatifs pour la
bureautique c'est loin et je dirais
également pour les mimes et très
clairement c'est pas du tout son adn est
à ce prix là à configuration équivalente
vous trouverez beaucoup moins cher à la
concurrence
quand vous aurez pas du tout cette
techno avec cette charnière avec le fait
qu'il soit détachables
avec ce 4 en 1 ça c'est vraiment l'adn
de cette surface bill 2 personnellement
je trouve un autre mode qui est
vachement intéressant c'est le fait de
le positionner comme ça comme ça c'est
vraiment pratique pour visionner du
contenu multimédia
ça marche très bien c'est plutôt cool à
la regarder
est-ce que c'est pas cool comme ça et
maintenant le duo rare qu'est ce que ça
dit parce que c'est bien beau d'avoir un
bel écran mais est-ce que l'audio et
coutras
on a des haut parleurs sur les côtés
juste ici mais également juste ici le
son est ok c'est pas elles sont le plus
dingue c'est pas la qualité est la plus
folle ça marche très bien qu'on nous
annonce du dolby audio premium
j'ai envie de dire ok par contre je suis
pas vraiment bluffé par le dos là dessus
raconte la position des haut parleurs
est vraiment très très bien le fait que
vous ayez sur le côté la justice'' sur
le haut est juste là de notre côté donc
le son est clair le son est cool bon
dans ce côté-là ça fonctionne également
très bien au final la donne de ce
produit c'est la robustesse le fait que
ce soit un produit complètement unique
que je trouve juste génial moi je sais
pas vous mais moi quand j'étais gamin je
rêvais d'avoir un ordinateur que je
puisse tourner il y avait eu des espèces
de deux systèmes un peu comme on avait
sur les pda sur les palm avant que savez
vous le preniez vous tombiez l'écran
vous pouvez les rabattre et j'ai rêvé
d'avoir ça sur mon ordinateur
malheureusement à l'époque c'est
absolument pas possible alors celui là
c'est pas système de palme ou relève ont
tourné hors pôles tels que techniquement
ça serait un peu plus fragiles là on
peut néanmoins le faire on prend on
enlève on peut l'emmener avec soit le
mode tablette voilà c'est vraiment ça
qui est bien
c'est un produit qui est complètement
unique complètement atypique qui
complètement adaptable à tous les
besoins mais par contre c'est un produit
qui n'est pas du tout du tout cadeau si
vous commencez à 15,5 à des cui giga de
ram voudrait prendre moins de 1000 euros
ça reste très honnête vu la techno que
vous avez là si vous l'utilisez juste
pour de la bureautique vous ai pas
besoin de beaucoup de puissance mais
vous adorez ce système des terres
adaptable et vous voulez vraiment un
produit vous pouvez adapter pour faire
un peu de retouches de crayon apple
photoshop
enfin sans vraiment besoin de puissance
bon cette machine fera très bien la
faire si par contre vous avez besoin de
puissance c'est une à six auxquelles il
faut mettre un i7 derrière sur lequel il
faut 16 giga de ram par contre on arrive
à 3700 et quelques euros avec intérêts
si je vais sur un terrain là c'est un
peu un peu gourmand si vous voulez pas
et sur un terrain vous prenez 1 512 giga
choix vous êtes à 3200 euros
on est quand même sur des prêts qui sont
hyper hyper élevé par contre en terme de
techno en termes d' usage en terme de
bad apte à billy t c'est un produit qui
est juste magique lé en plus de ça ce
qui est super cool pour utiliser le
stylet surface de microsoft et notamment
justement pour les infographistes pour
pouvoir bosser dessus c'est un petit
régal il ya peine accessoire microsoft
vous pouvez
dessus qui sont vraiment hyper hyper
hyper appréciable hyper hyper cool ça ça
vous intéresse je vous laisse découvrir
directement sur le site de microsoft
et si ce produit vous intéresse je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description bon et vous dites moi qu'est
ce que vous en pensez comment vous le
trouvez comment vous la trouvez la voix
est là comment vous la trouvez cette
surface book 2 de microsoft est ce que
vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
est-ce que vous avez déjà des produits
microsoft je pense à une sur facebook
sortie n'est pas très longtemps
c'est vraiment un petit petit bijou
franchement qui très très bien pour son
prix super rapport qualité prix je pense
aussi à la surface pro vous ne marquez
tout ça vous dit ce que vous en pensez
et puis près du général qu'est ce que
vous pensez des produits microsoft aux
peaux qui m'intéresse vraiment à savoir
ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
charnière ce côté esthétique est ce que
vous aimez cette esthétique est ce que
vous trouvez que leur système
aimanté qui vient s'ouvrir se fermer est
ce que vous le trouvez cool est ce que
c'est un produit qui pourrait vous
intéresser
la surface book de et puis peut-être que
vous l'avez déjà parce que elle vient
pas de sortir elle se sentit il ya
quelques temps vous marquez tout ça bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire vous
avez vu des ordinateurs on en parle de
plus en plus on va continuer ensuite je
trouve vraiment hyper intéressant de
voir à l'innovation au niveau du pc voit
où est-ce qu'on peut aller avec on a
tous des pc à la maison même si on a des
tablettes une sur des smartphones le pc
reste quand même un petit peu un
incontournable pour de la bureautique
malgré tout donc on va en parler encore
plus dans les temps à venir on va
laisser encore plus 2 pc merci soyez
sages vous marquez tout ça et je vous
invite à aller consulter ma playlist
vous présente un peu tous les différents
ordinateurs portables tablettes et
compagnies comme ça beau faire un avis
beaucoup plus précis je donne rendez
vous dès demain d'ici là soyez sages
portez vous bien nous en masse
ciao
non